hello i'm ed conway i cover economics
and do lots of numbers and stuff for sky
news and as you know
probably i have done a lot of the data
analysis when it comes to cover 19 and
so one of the things i wanted to do
was having seen all of those charts do
you remember those charts we saw over
the weekend
from the prime minister chief medical
officer about
covert 19 and about the reasons for
going into a second lockdown in england
i wanted to just try and go through that
data and see if we can understand
what it's actually saying because it
wasn't that clear to me and in
particular there was one thing the prime
minister said which left out
and you'll have heard it a bit elsewhere
if i zoom into this this was the part of
the statement that you produced
afterwards
the virus is now spreading even faster
than the reasonable worst
case scenario now that is a big deal if
it's doing worse in the worst case
scenario
except here's the thing you know i've
been following this quite a lot
i don't really know what the reasonable
worst case scenario is
and you might think when you hear
those words worst case scenario what
might jump out into your mind
is something like this this was um a
chart that surpassed
violence produced in mid-september
suggesting what could happen
to cases of covert 19 in the uk if they
were allowed
to to rise exponentially and what he
showed was it rising very sharply from
around 3000 new cases
this is daily reported cases on the 15th
of september up to 49
000 um by mid october very high number
and
it's worth asking the question if that's
the reasonable worst case scenario are
we indeed doing worse than that because
that would be really
really terrifying there is the doubling
every seven days line
and let's see what's actually happened
have a look at this
actually reported cases actual reported
cases and for that matter i put on cases
by specimen date
have risen far less quickly than that
reasonable worst case scenario
actually they're up by about if you kind
of look at this it's more or less
doubling every 10 days
which is still not good but it's nowhere
near doubling every seven days there's a
big difference as you can probably see
and in fact actually reported cases
they're doing it's a bit worse than
we're seeing in spain and in france i
thought at the time maybe spain and
france is a
clearer kind of path for where we might
head it's a bit less bad
it's a bit worse than that but it's it's
less bad than either doubling every
seven days or every 10 days
so as i say it's not good news but it's
certainly nowhere near that scenario if
we're calling that a scenario now
hang on you might well be saying um
isn't the real point of this
the fact that it's going up to 49 000
and probably
you might have seen elsewhere figures
showing that indeed cases have risen
to the daily rate of cases has risen
above 49
50 000. for instance the ons survey so
this is the
the definitive survey how much covert
there is in the country that shows cases
at around
52 000 uh a day now
here's the thing though that actually is
apples and pears that's a different
measurement
what sir patrick was talking about was
uk reported cases a day and there's a
reason
there's a reason it's worth just
underlining the difference between the
two things
reported cases today are only going to
be the tip of the iceberg about how much
covert there is in the country
the ons is trying to measure total how
much there is even
amongst people who haven't been tested
whereas reported cases is purely the
total number of people who get
a positive test on a given day or at
least
gets reported on that given day there's
a big difference and let me just show
you why that
why it's important to distinguish here
and why you shouldn't really take
seriously if someone says look we're at
fifty thousand therefore
so bachelor of alliance was right that's
not at all right
and here's why so at the middle of
september
the daily reported cases were around
three thousand that chart you just saw
from symmetra violence
ons infections that stage was around
seven thousand and if you're going to do
the same exercise so doubling every
seven days
for ons cases then look what happens
it goes up far more sharply up to around
160 000 infections
by the middle of october and compare
that with where we are in
actual reality and there is an enormous
difference
so whatever you measure you use as long
as you're consistent in comparing the
right things
that projection that we heard about in
september we are nowhere near it
so that's something of a relief um but
it doesn't clear up this
issue as to whether that was indeed the
worst case scenario so for instance
jeremy farah who is a member of sage
he said and this is a tweet just a few
days ago on 21st of september
uh some actual violence so as chris
whittie advised the uk could face fifty
thousand covert cases by mid-october two
thousand
uh two hundred deaths i should say uh by
mid-november these based on sage
reasonable worst case scenario so he
says they
that those lines you just saw were the
worst case scenario which is a little
odd isn't it
they were widely derived at the time
sorry guilty
uh both have proved underestimates of
true infections and deaths well
on the death side that's certainly true
although there was a question mark over
the time
at the time as to whether 200 deaths was
actually slightly an undershoot because
if you're talking about 50 000 cases
that would imply deaths of at least kind
of five
six hundred potentially maybe getting up
towards a thousand
whereas this talks about two thousand
but at this point
both have proved underestimates of true
infections death it's just plain wrong
that the sir patrick balance 50 000 has
not come to pass
nowhere near it and this presentation
from a member of sage i find slightly
alarming because it's it's changing the
goal posts after the fact
it's revisionist history it's not the
first time actually if you look at
something else that
jeremy farah said a few days later we
surpassed the reasonable worst case
scenarios
that uk science chief said that's
patrick valance and chris whitty
cmo england and sage outlined in
september
we won't see the sad consequences of
level uh until
the start of december now again
this is revisionist history if indeed
that september illustration was the
worst case scenario
no we are nowhere near it we're not in a
good place
but we're nowhere near it and i don't
see how it you know
encourages trust in our scientific
community to
change the goal post to you know expose
decide that
you were victorious no there was an
illustration
and it was unrealistic and we have
had an increase in cases that is not
good but it's been nowhere near that
illustration
um anyway it does raise another question
as to whether there's a different
worst case scenario going around here so
is there actually a worst case scenario
which where against which
the recent kind of increase in cases
does look quite bad and the answer is
yes so just the other day the spectator
managed to get hold of a copy of a worst
case scenario from july
and here's what it looked like this
shows number of new infections per week
under the reasonable worst case that is
rwc not rugby world cup unfortunately
planning scenario and certainly on this
basis on this worst case scenario the uk
is doing worse what i've got is i've
just put that onto
onto a chart so i can superimpose what's
actually happened and here's what's
actually happened look
a very big increase in comparison with
that july worst case scenario that does
not look good
at all and that i presume
is what they're really talking about in
downing street because
this obviously is worse there's i don't
think they're talking it's four times
worse actually
i don't think they're talking about that
that is the patrick balance illustration
by the way
we're almost vertical doubling every
seven days the reason it looks more
sharp is because these are just weekly
numbers
um but that would be talking about a
million
weekly cases by late october whereas
we're nowhere near that but we're still
we're not
in a good place and we are worse than
this july worst case scenario and i
should say it wasn't just cases that
um the leaked documents talked about
they also talked about deaths as well
and when you look at deaths as well you
can see that right now
look at the black line it's risen above
where
uh those deaths uh were expected to be
on the basis of the worst case scenario
but you're probably wondering there is a
another kind of thing that's a little
fishy about this
why was the worst case scenario if
indeed it was a genuine worst case
scenario talking about such a flat level
of covert
throughout the autumn most of us know
and realize that that's the period when
you've got you've got students going
back to university you've got
kids going back to school it is the kind
of period and it's the start of winter
as well it's the kind of period where
you are more likely to see a tick up
in the disease and yet the worst case
scenario didn't
pre-figure that at all but what's
interesting actually is if you take this
worst case scenario for deaths and
just imagine that they did get it right
on the timing and they thought that the
the infections were going to rise in
september late september
october as they have done let's just
move that forward in time a little bit
and compare that with the line that we
actually have
there you can see the black line is what
actually happened in terms of deaths and
the white line is the worst case
scenario and on that basis
if this would just move forward a bit
then perhaps
we'd be more or less in line with it not
saying that's a good thing but the idea
of us being
way out way above the worst case
scenario is slightly you know it's a
question of timing
maybe it's just the timing was way out
by a month and a half
and actually we're more or less in line
with what was expected
um i should say though you know this
this dates from
july this original worst case scenario
uh and clearly
you know it hasn't been updated for a
while but it does seem as if in the
meantime the prime minister has got some
other measures that he wanted to show us
and so when
we got those charts over the weekend
they didn't include this but they did
include
this very scary chart showing your
potential death
rate so this is showing death rates from
a number of different places i'll show
you which ones in a moment
and what can happen in the next few
months and
all of them pretty much showing that the
number of deaths would go above the
peak in the first wave and what they've
actually done here this is sage putting
together
a number of different models uh from
epidemic models from public health
england and cambridge mrc biostats
imperial college there london school of
hygiene and tropical medicine and
warwick as well
the one that probably leaps out though
is that one the cambridge one which is
talking about four thousand daily deaths
and there was a headline actually after
after that press conference look it
could be facing four thousand daily
deaths
if we don't go into lockdown and that's
this is supposed to be part of the
justification
for lockdown and it's an important thing
and it's good to some extent that we're
now seeing this data
but here's the slightly odd thing these
lines actually are a bit old they go
back about a month or so
and so what we can do is to plot what's
actually happened to deaths
since those lines came along and work
out whether it's in line
with these terrifying lines i don't know
we can't really call these worst case
scenarios because they're alternative
illustrations
that they're feeding into sage but even
so we know they're feeding in
um and we can work out whether we are in
line with it and what happens if we plot
actual deaths well have a look at this
actually it's difficulty so i'm going to
zoom in
so you can get a sense of where we are
in relation to those lines and you can
perhaps see there
the actual deaths this black line is
below
all of these plots all of these models
for what might happen to deaths we're
undershooting it already
and let's hope that remains the case but
that certainly wasn't something that
came out of the prime minister's
presentation um and it actually if you
look if you take specifically this blue
scary line the one that goes up to four
thousand
now that's from this excellent team at
cambridge who are looking at
what happens with this disease and they
interestingly are constantly updating
their model
and the version that the government
chose was one from i think the start of
october october the 12th
but since then as you can see things
have changed
so they have changed their model which
is interesting isn't it so
let me just kind of underline what we're
talking about here that's what's
happened to actual death so each day you
can see each daughter's a number of
people
who have died on each day and that's the
line that cambridge
uh provided to sage which they've put in
that scary
dossier over the weekend but since then
a week later they updated the line and
it got a bit more shallow
a week after that they updated the line
again
and it's even more shallow and that's
their up-to-date line
it's not the four thousand deaths one
it's one that's more shallow
it might get up to four thousand deaths
we don't annoyingly
like so many pieces of these data we
don't get them released publicly
but for the time being actually the the
outlook and the projection of where
uk deaths are from covert 19 is
more benign than it was in those charts
that we saw over the weekend
and that's just on the basis of data
that's actually out since then
so things aren't quite as bad as that
but that's not to say they're good but
what
is frustrating and i've said it a few
times and i'll probably say again before
the end
is the fact that it's not easy to get a
hold of these numbers they're not being
provided by the government as a matter
of course
they're not telling us what their
reasonable worst case scenario is they
don't tell us what the story is they
just say oh we've broken it
they need to provide us with what the
actual scenario is and happily
now i think for the first time they
provide us with a bit more
uh data or at least a few more charts
they haven't made it easy for us to get
a hold of them i've had to trace some of
these ones here
um but for instance over the weekend
what we got was a projection of what
they expected to happen to deaths
so we'll keep an eye on that over the
next few weeks and work out whether we
are
really in line with where they think
we're heading of course
at some point the lockdown measures will
have an impact and will bear down
on this growth potentially but at least
for the next
two weeks or so before because it takes
about two weeks for the measures to kind
of be
seen on infection rates at least for the
next two weeks we'll get a sense of
whether that's
the right line or whether it's kind of
over um overstating it and the same
again for hospitalizations actually
we've had hospitalization data in uh
just the last day or two which look a
little bit better
than expected so again might it be the
case that this is
an overstatement and that we're not
necessarily going to hit that first
wave peak we will have to see but as i
say
it is disappointing let's say to put it
lightly at this stage in the pandemic a
pandemic that is all about data
that we're still having to extract this
stuff out of the government and
reverse engineer it and you know guess
basically because a lot of what i've
done has been guesswork i should say
at what they are trying to model inside
downing street
we need to know what the worst case
scenario is so we know whether we're
going to miss it or not
as it is all we know is that they say
that we've missed it and then
we can't even work out we're not even
told what the actual worst case scenario
is for those of us who follow data is
incredibly frustrating
but for everyone else it's frustrating
as well because what matters with a
pandemic is understanding what's
happening with the spread
and there is a lot of data out there
in the government's coffers which is not
releasing
and this is my final point really um
last
last week i don't know if you saw this
um i had the story about how the number
of care home cases in leeds and this is
what the line here
is number of care home cases and leads
has shot up and this basically shows you
that's the spring
rise in total covert cases and care
homes and leads and it goes down and
then it shoots up very sharply
um in the last week and a half and the
frustrating thing is
this data exists for pretty much every
area
of england and i presume it does for
scotland and wales too
and northern ireland as well but it's
not publicly released
it's not publicly released we wouldn't
know about the fact that there's a
sudden sharp uptick in care home cases
which is
deeply concerning given that that was
part of the problem that happened last
time
we wouldn't know about this had we at
sky news not managed to get a hold of it
this stuff should be released as a
matter of course this is
such an important point for the uk
economy
and for the uk you know health system
and for all of our well-being
and yet we're not being given the full
information about the state of the
disease
and it's unclear why not in other
countries around the world
many other countries belgium hong kong
taiwan
france as well they produce much more
data much more transparently
about what is happening with covert 19
and the more
data is produced the better an idea we
can have of
what's happening with this disease that
matters enormously
and yet it's as if the government
doesn't want to produce this stuff and
the nhs doesn't want to produce this
stuff publicly
and that's disappointing because until
it is
clear what's happening with this disease
it's unlikely that people are actually
going to
have their faith in the government and
faith in the nhs and as a result they
may not necessarily
be as likely to follow those lock down
rules it's about generating
trust in what you're doing as a
government and by not releasing this
data
and by coming up with spurious
explanations about
worst case scenarios that have been
missed without actually telling us what
the worst case scenario is
that doesn't really engender much trust